CBS News senior national security
analyst Fran Townsend was a homeland
security adviser for president george w
bush frank good morning obviously in a
circumstance like this we're looking for
more information
granted that that's her what's the beer
here so charlie remember that ice is
called for ramadan attacks and they'll
take this attack clearly against
worshipers coming out of a mosque during
the holy month and turn it to their
propaganda use to recruit to inspire
there's another week to ramadan and so
the big my big fear I think the British
big fear is that they'll use this to
sort of further inspire other attempt
what I read they already are that's
right that's exactly Isis yeah Fran
ramming style attacks with trucks vans
etc what can be done to prevent them at
this point short of having concrete
barriers in front of every public space
so the problem is right this is the
weapon of choice is when you can't
really restrict it's easily available
anybody can get it and so what you have
to do is identify the individual driving
it which is the single hardest thing for
investigators to do we don't know yet
was this planned was it premeditated in
some way or was it sort of a spontaneous
act but I'll tell you the act of the
crowd who held one of the alleged drive
the driver of the van reminded me of
United 93 on 9/11 where the community on
the plane decides to act together to
stop somebody this is the fish a third
ramming style attack in three months in
London does London need to change its
posture Kennett and and to Alex's point
how much can you actually prevent if
that's what they're determined to do
with this way so security services there
in the in London are very very good they
rival in terms of their strength and
capability US intelligence and law
enforcement the problem is they're
overwhelmed we've heard reports of as
many as 23 thousand potential extremists
that they need to watch that's
impossible and so what you have to do is
triage it and you're going to miss
people we don't know we really don't
know the motivation behind the sky and
the British press are restricted in what
they can say because you've got a
suspect captured alive who will face
prosecution if they go forward and so
the press there is
have to be pretty circumspect by law
about what they can say Fran Townsend
thanks for the update good thank you as
always